val there are three shots in your pistol
yet you had better discharge them what
for
to prevent any accident you might shoot
yourself no danger of that was the reply
evidently the writers of law and order
1871
were really into very obvious
foreshadowing
among the many sworn duties of lawyers
perhaps the most famous is that of
zealous advocate a lawyer is duty-bound
to do everything reasonable
and ethical to help a client achieve
their goals
the best lawyers burn the candle at both
ends with long hours and little sleep in
service of zealous representation
figuratively killing themselves for
their clients
but do you know the story of perhaps the
greatest defense attorney of all time
who took the oath of zealous advocacy
just a little too seriously by not
figuratively dying for his client but
literally dying for his client well
today we're going to discuss the curious
case of clement velandingham
whose novel legal defense got his client
acquitted of murder charges
at the cost of his own life and along
the way was found guilty of treason and
exiled before sneaking back into this
country in disguise
it's going to be a wild ride so let's
get started
brought to you by trade coffee clement
vallandigham was born on july 29
1820 in new lisbon ohio now just lisbon
ohio growing up he was best friends with
edwin
m stanton who would become the secretary
of war under president abraham lincoln
growing up vallandigham was close
friends with stanton
until falling out was caused not by
stealing each other's toys
but being on opposing sides of the civil
war as one
does but when they were still friends
stanton left vlantingham 500
for a law course and to begin his own
practice and after a short stint in the
ohio state legislature
vladingham ran for congress as a
democrat in 1856. despite being
narrowly defeated by 19 votes vladingham
appealed to the committee of
elections of the house of
representatives claiming illegal votes
denied him victory
after nearly two years of deliberation
the house eventually agreed and
velandingham
was seated for a two-day house term
thankfully we've come a long way since
1856 where
politicians just gracefully accept the
results of a lost
election
vlad decam was elected to a full term in
1858 and re-elected in 1860 before being
defeated in the 1862 election when the
u.s civil war broke out
congressman vladingham became the de
facto leader of the
copperheads a group of anti-war midwest
union democrats who opposed the u.s
civil war opposed the
abolition of slavery and demanded an
immediate peace settlement with the
confederacy and
yeah yeah for anyone trolling in the
comments section the democrats and the
republicans of the 1860s were not the
same as the democrats and republicans of
today so
just don't but the copperheads actively
resisted the draft
and encouraged union soldiers to desert
their units both in and out of congress
vladicam became one of abraham lincoln's
most outspoken critics which
managed to get velandingham in a bit of
trouble there's a good chance i may have
committed some
light treason but as the civil war
dragged on abraham lincoln began
undertaking some extraordinary and in
retrospect legally questionable measures
to crack down on war opponents in 1862
lincoln issued a proclamation suspending
habeas corpus meaning that
if you were detained you could no longer
seek a remedy in the courts to determine
if the
detention was lawful or not the
proclamation also made discouraging
enlistment
resisting drafts or any other disloyal
practice subject to martial law
and trial by a military commission but
enter major general
ambrose burnside famous for humiliating
military defeats
and for making sideburns a thing i
thought i told you to cut those
sideburns burn side what sideburn you've
heard me hippie
but after losing the battle of
fredericksburg and the battle of crater
lincoln demoted burnside and sentenced
him to
ohio where he quickly made a name for
himself a few weeks after velandingham
returned to ohio ambrose burnside made
his move against the rebel copperheads
in april 1863 burnside issued general
order number 38
which declared jedi's traitors to the
republic leading to the great jedi purge
no no that's that's not what happened uh
sorry wrong civil war but what
burnside's general order number 38 did
was to make it a crime in some cases
punishable by death to express public
opposition to the war
the order stated the habit of declaring
sympathy for the enemy will not be
allowed in this department
persons committing such offenses will be
at once arrested with a view of being
tried
or sent beyond our lines into the lines
of their friends it must be understood
the treason expressed or implied
will not be tolerated in this department
and of course the beatings will continue
until morale improves but on may 1
1863 now ex-congressman vallandigham
organized a rally in mount vernon ohio
denouncing the order the war and
demanding the immediate removal of
king lincoln and in his speech valedicam
unaware that union agents were in the
audience
taking notes asserted among other things
that the civil war was a sinister plot
not to preserve the union but to free
slaves and enslave whites in their place
and thank goodness we are a long way
past the days of public officials who
spout baseless conspiracy
theories velandikamp asserted the
constitution protected his right to
speak freely despite the order ambrose
burnside
disagreed and in the early hours of may
5th 1863
150 union soldiers surrounded
vlandicam's home
and arrested the former congressman for
treason and as a result veladingham was
brought before a military tribunal where
he refused to enter a plea
ever the lawyer he argued that the
military tribunal lacked jurisdiction to
hear his case
as he was not a member of the military
nor a resident of a state in rebellion
or in a state under martial law
and valenticam contended that the
constitution guaranteed his right to
have his case heard in a civil court
in front of a jury of his peers
guaranteed
under the constitution clear his day the
military tribunal
disagree vladicam was convicted of quote
uttering disloyal sentiments
and attempting to hinder prosecution of
the war and sentenced to two years
in a military prison vladim actually
appealed his case all the way to the
supreme court arguing that as a civilian
he could not be tried as a military
tribunal which gave rise to the ex parte
velandicam case in
ex parte vladingham the supreme court
sidestepping blandingham's
jurisdictional questions unanimously
ruled that the supreme court had no
power to even hear appeals
from military tribunals although
vallantakam lost this case
after the war the supreme court did
vindicate his position in a similar case
ex parte milligan the supreme court
ruled that trying civilians in military
tribunals is
unconstitutional when civilian courts
are available so
what happened next well abraham lincoln
commuted velandicam's sentence and
banished him
to the confederacy of all places vladim
though then sneaked into canada
ran for governor of ohio from a hotel in
ontario
and lost and then became the leader of
the paramilitary group the order of the
sons of liberty with the plan of
creating the
northwest confederacy by overthrowing
the state governments of ohio kentucky
indiana and illinois he was
anything if not ambitious but in june
1864 vladicam under heavy disguise
sneaked back into the u.s the intended
revolt never materialized though
several other members of the order of
the sons of liberty were convicted of
conspiracy to commit treason
by a military tribunal where of course
vladingham gave testimony only to have
their own
tribunal convictions thrown out by the
supreme court by you guessed it ex parte
milligan but after
failed bids in the senate and house
vladicam resumed his law practice
and this is where things get really
interesting because alas
twas the overzealous lawyering that
killed the congressman
in 1871 clement velandingham was halfway
through trying what he thought would be
the greatest case of his life but it
actually turned out to be
the last case of his entire life enter
his client one
thomas mcgee who had been charged with
the murder of a well-known local tough
guy in scoundrel
thomas myers and one fateful christmas
eve in hamilton ohio meyers had been
playing cards in a private room in a bar
where
five men burst into the room and a bar
room brawl broke out
as meyers rose from his seat rummaging
in his pocket to draw his pistol a
muffled shot was heard myers drew his
gun
fired a couple shots before he collapsed
dead those who witnessed the chaos kept
bringing up one murder suspect
thomas mcgee with whom myers had a
long-running feud but the defense's
theory was that
myers had in fact accidentally shot
himself in
all of the ruckus and ever the hands-on
lawyer velantingham
was dead set on proving this theory
correct to his co-counsel
so like any good defense attorney
vladingham began
inspecting the murder weapon and after
firing two
rounds of his five-shot smith and wesson
revolver into a square of cloth to
test whether it would leave a mark of
powder vladingham headed back to the
hotel with his co-counsel newspaper
accounts at the time recounted the
following conversation that would
portend
vladingham's impending demise co-counsel
milken ever cautious and thoughtful said
val there are three shots in your pistol
yet you had better discharge them what
four
responded mr valanticham to prevent any
accident replied the cautious attorney
you might shoot yourself no danger of
that replied mr vladingham
i carried and practiced with pistols too
long to be afraid to have loaded one in
my pocket you'd better be careful though
said mr milliken never fear me was the
reply
evidently the writers of law and order
1871
were really into very obvious
foreshadowing
and when vallanticam returned to the
hotel he received a package
an unloaded revolver that had been used
as a trial exhibit back in the hotel
room velandicam placed both weapons on
the table
side by side and as other lawyers joined
him
in the room vladigam proceeded to test
his theory that tom myers
shot himself bladdingham accidentally
grabbing the loaded gun because
obviously he placed the revolver in his
pocket and slowly drew it out
he pointed the gun at his abdomen in the
exact position he believed myers shot
himself
thinking the gun was unloaded he pulled
the trigger
my god i've shot myself vladnik
hammock's claimed as he reeled towards
the wall
at least four jurors who were staying at
the hotel
entered the room to see what had
transpired words spread throughout the
town
maybe there was something to
vladingham's theory well
vladim died the next morning his final
words were
i may however be mistaken but i am a
firm believer
in the good old presbyterian doctrine of
predestination
so what happened afterwards well after
two trials first a hung jury and then a
second-degree murder conviction that was
set aside for jury misconduct
and lack of evidence mcgeehan was
acquitted in his third trial
so great job clement after his acquittal
mcgeehan published a self-serving
autobiographical work entitled thomas
mcgee in a history of the life and
trials of thomas mcgee mcgean actually
used a print of vladicam shooting
himself
as the cover and after being run out of
town mcgeehan soon returned to hamilton
ohio
only to realize he still had enemies and
the universe has a dark sense of humor
so
after being acquitted for murder in a
bar room brawl by potentially the
greatest defense attorney of all time
mcgean would soon meet his end being
shot to death in a bar as reported by
the whimsically named tiffin tribune the
hamiltonians threatened to take his life
if he attempted
to make his home in that city and they
evidently don't like to be caught in a
lie about a small matter of that kind
as for ambrose burnside well mr
sideburns was elected to be the first
president
of the nra yes that nra and that my
friends is the curious case of clement
velandingham potentially
the greatest defense attorney of all
time and if there's any takeaways from
this
it's probably that when your co-counsel
warns you not to shoot yourself
you should probably take that advice but
this is not the end
of the story you see the universe really
does have
a dark sense of humor and the universe
was not finished
with clement of landing him as reported
by the fife herald at the time
hardly was vladingham in his grave
before another man killed himself while
trying to precisely in the same way to
demonstrate how mr vlandingham had met
his death i know you think that lawyers
are super smart
but some aren't and while this is a
tragic example of client advocacy gone
wrong remember
the 1800s were a much different time and
thankfully
today we are much more responsible in
how we handle our firearms
you might ask yourself how was it
possible that clement flandingham
actually shot himself well
it was probably because he was under
caffeinated because a lawyer is only as
good as their most recent cup of coffee
and i get my coffee from trade and
trade's great because not only do they
have a huge selection of your favorite
coffees but they also have an
awesome quiz to get you matched with
coffee recommendations based on your
taste
preferences i basically want something
that tastes like hot chocolate and pairs
well with a ton
of milk and sugar and trade was able to
find me the perfect roast and with trade
you can discover new coffees from the
nation's top roasters because trade
learns your preferences over time and
pairs you with a personal selection of
coffee conveniently delivered straight
to you
and if you already know what you like
then they probably already have your
favorite roaster in stock at a great
price
so if you would like to try trade coffee
legal eagles will get 50
off their first bag when they sign up
and get free shipping so just click on
the link in the description take the
quiz
and choose your frequency whether you
want one bag or a whole bunch
and then rate your coffee so your
suggestions get even better over time
you can even choose whole beans or your
preferred grind it's really the best
coffee website out there
so to get 50 off of your first order
click on the link in the description
or use the promo code legal50 at
checkout plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel so do you
agree with my analysis
of the famous incident of clement
velandingham leave your objections in
the comments and check out this playlist
over here with
all sorts of crazy legal oddities and
ridiculous things in the legal world
so click on this playlist or i'll see
you in court